one really great thing that we're
finding this here is you've got a large
number of women who are taking the
course we really tried it to focus on
getting a good balance of diversity of
voices in the course of i think 65 we're
going to have 25 women first day and
we're doing it basically this first day
is to see what we can do to keep them to
keep them engaged and keep them as part
of the course we have had like in the
last the last couple of years we've had
almost twice as many or three times as
many women on our first day and by our
second week we'll be down to only four
or five women in the class out of you
know 30 30 odd people so so we're really
hoping that we can do a better job at
keeping them this year trying a couple
of new techniques this year we we put a
harassment policy into our syllabus as
well as to an initial email that went
out to all of the students just making
it clear that no it's not okay to to
harass ought to make your your
classmates feel uncomfortable and if you
are in a position where you feel
uncomfortable you can always speak to
the instructors a lot of this is just
stand at MIT policy but it's not normal
practice for classes to actually stated
up front still we want the students to
understand that they have these options
what we're what we also try to do is
make sure that we have a lot of women
speaking in our classes so lecturers for
instance or guests we try to make sure
that it's very easy to be able to see
yourself as a professional because all
you get all our speakers work in games
in some manner or other I mean we're not
entirely sure why we're losing um so
many women and because it's all in the
beginning it's not it's not that we lose
them later on we have women the women
who go through our class we get a very
high percentage of them coming back for
617 the advanced game studio course so
um the ones we've got them in the class
once they once they decide it's going to
be an interesting
class to take we seem to keep them the
question is how can we keep from
scattering them off in that first week
which is when MIT students can say oh
you know what this class looks like I
think it would take some other class so
I think it's we've we've put more of our
work into focusing our upfront making it
clear what the course is about and
trying to make sure that we are in fact
being welcoming yeah yeah lot of it has
to do with being welcoming but also
providing challenges that more people
might be interested in so in this case
it's not nationally targeting women but
really to starting a diverse group of
voices in the class so for this semester
the design challenge we're we're really
focusing on what the design challenges
is in the classrooms from day one we're
in previous semesters we talked about it
a little bit in the first couple of
weeks and then we didn't get into a deep
ler deeper until midway through so in
this case the semester it's about
decision making in games we're talking
about the types of games many different
kinds of students would want to play and
have played so it's not just that you're
coming to a game course because you play
all sorts of games and then you find out
well this one's just going to be about
war games so talking about narrative
talking about fiction also talking about
strategy talking about chance and talk
about all the different elements that
are going to they're going to explore
over the next semester in the beginning
hopefully we'll we'll keep them
interested and then also having aid
clients in the class where they're
actually making a game that's going to
do some some good to somebody else it's
not they're not just making a game to
make a game in this case the games
they're making are going to be used by
the Red Cross Red Crescent Climate
Center particularly to make to help
policymakers better understand the need
to devote resources time and money to
disaster preparedness so it's a big
topic it's a timely topic climate change
is being talked about a lot right now
MIT students like those kinds of MIT
styled like engineering problems so
hopefully that also keeps a good number
of the students keeping it in the course
after the first week
we don't have we never have a problem
keeping our number hi our number is
always high it's keeping the diverse
number of voices hi from the get-go